in a remote beautiful part of ireland
dream homes have turned to nightmares
across county donegal thousands of
families have watched as their homes
start to crumble to dust well as you can
see the the cracks
are just getting worse every day and all
the cornerstones have
started coming away and busting it's
just crumbling away here crumbling away
yeah you can fit your hand in and then
the bits are coming off and it's just
constant the problem is mica
defective building blocks containing
high levels of the mineral were used in
at least five
thousand homes in donegal and mayo
during the celtic tiger boom years
now they're disintegrating more
don't know there we go
what does it feel like to live in a
house that is it it really is literally
just crumbling crumbling away
i wasn't expecting that um yeah
crumbling away
it must be scary because it's very scary
um
especially when it's so quiet at
nighttime yes
you can hear the crumbling you can hear
the pop cracking
the popping and the banging and some
debris falling off
a short distance away in buncrana is the
home of claire mcdade
originally from london an engineer has
recommended the mica affected house be
demolished
demolition it's it's a hard thing to
face
stephen it's a really hard thing to face
and to have to come to terms with the
fact that
you know apart from the financial
implications
the the stress it's just it's very hard
to put into words how hard it
how stressful it is
[Music]
[Applause]
the mcdade and mclaughlin families were
among thousands who travel to a protest
outside the
irish parliament the government now says
it will change the scheme
everyone agrees we have to protect you
know people who've at risk of losing
their homes
we don't want to see that happen i think
women can't say today
that they will commit to 100 no because
you'd get this right a working group
will now report back to the government
at the end of july as their homes
continue to disintegrate
families insist that anything less than
100 compensation will be a betrayal
and lead to further protests stephen
murphy's sky news
in county donegal